welcome to gamespot of Thrones you are
watching just a mere clip from a much
longer show where myself Kate and Dave
talk about Game of Thrones like the
massive nerds that we are so make sure
to come join us at youtube.com slash
gamespot or at gamespot com or on iTunes
hopefully we'll see they're not to blow
our own trumpets here but we did pretty
well with the predictions that we made
last week so we totally called the
Ramseys gonna kill ruse you totally
called The Princess Bride resurrection
yeah and hey mutton risky and we totally
called that um you know Terry and
dragons of play part yes so we're doing
pretty well this week I'm gonna start
off with bastard Bowl which i think is
really exciting so we know that Ramsey I
mean I actually first let's have a
moment of silence for Roose Bolton um
you know rip it's his own fault really
he should just see what Ramsay even
betrayed I have no sympathy for that man
so we know Ramsay definitely wants to
take on Castle black he wants to kill
Jon Snow and he thinks that he has all
the Northern armies in which to do so so
he's got the umbers the Karstarks and
the man delays we don't need every house
in the north the umbers the mandala sand
the karst dogs command more soldiers
than all the other houses combined with
air support none co challenges so he's
got like a pretty sizable force and as
he says like the Castle black it's just
like rapists and murderers and petty
thieves they're not really trained
there's not very many of them and it's
not defended from the south either yeah
so he sees this as a pretty easy win but
he also doesn't know that John died and
has been resurrected and is now kind of
scene is like this godlike figure from
the wildlings and also that he's managed
to get the wildlings on side and the
wildlings I mean there's a lot of them
and a giant yep oh yeah and a giant I'm
guessing he definitely doesn't know
about when when the Giants so we also
know that Sansa's on her way up there to
reunite with John so John like before
he's always been a man of honor doesn't
want to get involved but now he has like
this personal connection mm-hmm so he's
gonna want revenge on behalf of
answer so if we take like if you look at
like a book theory here so when Lady
Stoneheart was resurrected it was
Catelyn Stark and she was kind of
overcome with vengeance so I'm
interested to see if John will be
different if he won't be like as
honorbound and peaceful us before if he
will be like more Lord stone ha let's
just say time to kick some ass John yeah
nice kick in John um but also to do with
bastard bowl I hang this line from the
current Lord Karstark is quite
interesting and I think it leads into
what's gonna happen next week your hold
on the north will never be secured as
long as a star can walk through that
door and in the trailer for episode 3 we
hear someone say I brought you a gift
and right before that happens that flag
looks a lot like the ombre flag and we
know that Rick on was taken there so
basically if Ramsey's gift cuz we when
we were watching we wish we thought it'd
be reek Ryan the kid he's been captured
and returned him yeah but really all
Ramsay needs is a stark in the north and
if he's got recon whatever forgot about
the worst of the Starks well bran yeah
no I mean so like he basically has
everything so here's everything he needs
john wants like revenge bastard all guys
snowball snowball none of the bastards
but all of the bastards there's so many
I mean the show has so many balls I do
think as well next episode is called
Oathbreaker and we are thinking that
maybe the person breaking their oath is
jon snow because you only have to keep
the Nights Watch oath until you die and
he died that's brilliant Gregory think
about that oh no cuz we hey when we
already went and we thought he'd be like
Brienne because her sword is obvious
called oathkeeper but she's fulfilled
her oath now yeah she's found Santa so
Kate gray excellent work
you